well we're your local election
headquarters after a night of waiting
the november matchups are set one
candidate for governor isn't conceding
the 8 news now i-team's david charns
joins us live in studio with a breakdown
of the numbers and what joey gilbert is
saying on social media david yeah guys
joe gilbert is standing right here
during our gubernatorial debate just a
couple of weeks ago he lost the race to
clark county sheriff joe lombardi you
see here joel o'mara with 38 of the vote
if you look at this counting by county
the darker the red the better libardo in
the race
and we do apologize we're just adjusting
some microphone issues there and then
we'll take david back again
let's go back to david now
that's the power it's the power of
television right all right so let's go
over that again uh joe lombardo winning
this race against joey gilbert by 38
the darker the color here the better
that lombardo did in the state so you
see here he really
won by a large margin here in clark
county of course his home county but if
you go farther north in places like
washoe county where joey gilbert is from
he actually won that by about three
points now we reached out to gilbert's
campaign today we did not hear back we
don't know if he will request a formal
recount but i want to show you this this
is what he put on social media last
night he said in part i smell a lawsuit
and again we reached out to the campaign
today and asked if there will be a
recount and we have not gotten an answer
yet now if gilbert or anybody else does
request a recount there are rules here
in our state they are not automatically
triggered the candidate has three
working days from when the election is
certified that's in a couple days to
request one and they have to pay for the
cost so when we look forward to november
we're talking about governor sisilak
against joe lombardo the other big race
was former attorney general adam laxalt
against of course sam brown to get that
nomination to run against democratic
senator catherine cortez masto her
campaign already out with an ad blasting
laxalt today you see here all the red
here shows that lock cell pretty much
won 16 out of our 17 counties so the
matchups are set guys now comes more ads
and money in these races that both
democrats and republicans want to win
here's